Hey, what's going on? Bill? Burn
his time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday
morning podcast. Dan,
I'm just checking in on you. I'm
just checking in on you. Oh, needy.
What are you going going to go work out.
There you go. Get on the elliptical.
Do it. All right. That was part
of our prenuptial agreement.
Keep it looking good.
It's exactly what it is.
You would never dare try to get
a prenuptial agreement with me.
What are you talking about?
I'm throwing it out there right now.
I'm going to get up post married,
prenuptial postnuptial agreement.
No, I'm going to get all
right. It's mine. All mine.
You know I don't even give a shit.
You want all this stuff? I don't care.
It's a fucking headache. As long as they
got enough for a sandwich. I'm good.
I want every color of izod shirt.
Yeah,
seriously though.
Okay.
I will.
I will leave you.
There's a certain level that if
you allow it, if you drop below,
I'm walking his bald,
pasty,
redheaded male pushing
50 yeah. Good luck. Okay.
Don't look at me like I
don't have options. Woman.
I've been out to the strip
malls. I've seen the looks. Okay.
You put me in a strip
mall near that has a,
a dentist and a place where
they do your taxes. Okay.
Fucking hedges whipping around.
Yeah.
Uh, she could at least pretend that
I'm still kind of good looking. Right.
All right. Anyways, what's up everybody?
How are you? How's your week going?
Is it going bad? Well, it's almost over.
At least the bad part of it is,
Huh? How about a moment of silence?
How about a fun moment of silence for
everybody who sitting in a fucking place
they don't want to be right now, Huh?
There was your moment and you know what?
That's all you deserve. Why
are you still there? Stand up.
Push that plastic wheelchair
away from that fucking,
I know what I want you to do, right?
Don't do that. You need a plan.
Come up with a fucking plan
and my stomach's can be
grounded like crazy. I just,
I just got off of a, got off of
the plane, had a 7:00 AM flight,
um, came back from New
York. I went to the, uh,
and it's just an amazing, a
memorial service for Charlie
Murphy yesterday. And uh,
I got to tell you this, um, cause you
know, it's a private ceremony. Some,
I can give any details, but I will
tell you this, you know, Comedians,
we, a lot of us may die young, but I will
tell you this, we have great funerals.
It's fucking unbelievable.
It was unbelievable. They,
a New York legend was sent
off by legends. It was, um,
it was incredible. It was
really incredible. So. MMM.
Yeah, I'm still sad though.
Obviously still sad, but he
would have been very happy.
I'm like morning to speak for
him. Anything but like, uh,
I hope I get sent off
that. Well, it was a, yeah,
there was definitely something else.
So that's quite built,
bring up something that you're not going
to really give any details of. Well,
you know, whatever. I
just, I just, so anyways,
so everybody hung out afterwards to like
two 30 in the morning and I had like a,
you know,
7:00 AM flight and
the only way to it, there's two
ways to handle a 7:00 AM flight,
which is gonna involve like
a fucking 4:30 AM pickup.
All right?
There's only two ways to do it.
You either go to bed, you know,
you drink some hot cocoa at 7:00 PM and
you figure out how you're going to get
your fucking eight hours, whatever you
do. What do people do with your pills?
Is that what you do? Well, you sit fucking
Indian style foot of your bed going,
okay,
oh,
whatever is whatever that
meditation should is all
right. Which I have not done.
And I'll tell you the ramifications
of that here in a minute. Um,
do the do that or you just
stay out drinking with your
friends to like two 30 in
the morning and then you come home,
you get about an hour and a half,
two hours sleep, you stagger to the
fucking airport, whatever, out to the cab.
You go in there and you just,
the the biggest thing is not to nod
off at the gate, you got to stay awake,
but the lights are on in that type of
shit. And then once you get to your seat,
that's it. Then you're out.
You're out at sea. It's fucking,
and that's a great way to do it.
Cause then you don't have to sit there
bored out of your mind on the flight.
You know,
by the way,
thanks to the person that sent me that
fucking creepy video of that plane crash
in which for some dumb reason,
I'm sitting there watching it.
But the tail section
coming off this plane,
these pilots trying to figure out
a fucking way to try to land it,
which of course you can at that point.
Um,
I wasn't surprised that they didn't
invert. That's always a fun thing.
Half asleep to be watching because you
know, you have a sleep going like, wait,
am I on this flight or is this a, is
this a, should I be feeling that failing?
You know, they sent me this video and
I'm not getting on this plane. Well,
you know what?
I got on that God plane and I went
right to sleep and woke up like,
you know, five hours later, five hours
later on a six hour flights. Perfect.
You know,
they come over, sir. Would
you like anything? Would you
catch a kid? Well, my job.
Well I go, yeah. What do you
got? Well, we got a mush rob.
We got a a Portobello mushroom
sandwich. Yeah, that's sounds gross.
What else she got? I don't even
know what the other thing was.
I thought when she said the
mushroom thing with the other thing,
I thought it was all the same thing.
I go,
is that all one thing or is that two
things? She goes, that's two things.
And I went,
all right,
okay.
I, I don't want anything. I got a
new thing. I don't eat on planes.
I'm not fucking doing it. I'm not
fucking doing it. It's just, it's,
it's fucking shit food. Empty
going to do it. You're like,
I'm fucking five miles up from the
surface of the, of the, of, of the earth.
You know,
the only thing you should be eaten up
there as shit that you shouldn't be like,
like Pringles potato chips and stuff.
Why would you eat those?
And you'd just sit in there, you get
beat, just becoming a fat fuck. So, uh,
I sort of been doing this thing this
year is I'm trying to fucking drop some
weight here. You know, even though I'm
a dad, I'm not going to have the fun,
I'm not having the fucking
dad bod not having that thing.
You know the thing when you go to lift
up your arms just shirt comes up and it's
just that fucking pork shoulder spilling
out on the side and ain't happening to
me. Um, I was speaking of
which, so, uh, you know,
I packed hastily cause I,
I when I went to Boston first
and then to New York and uh,
so I grabbed a suit and everything
in my shoes. So I have them, uh,
for the memorial service and I forgot
to bring dark socks. All right.
And also I was working out and doing the
elliptical and all that type of stuff.
So I thought it brought enough boxers
and I didn't. So I was like, fuck.
So I landed in New York,
I get to the hotel and it's, you
know, would like in midtown and shit.
We meaning me and all my
fucking personalities. And uh,
so I called me up. I tell her where
I'm at. I was like, fuck, you know,
the car's coming to get me to take me over
to the service, you know, I need some,
uh, underwear, which should I
go, there's, this is New York.
There's no fucking gaps anywhere.
They're all like downtown or way up town.
And I'm right in the middle.
I don't have time.
And she asked me where I was at and
she goes, oh, I ain't know that.
And I was like, I guess
like a gay neighborhood. She
goes, go around the corner,
there's upstairs and one of those fucking
stores. So we've got across the store,
right straight, right. And
there's like, you know,
the second you see the
mannequins, you know what I
mean? You know that it's, yeah,
this is like a, it's a gay
store. It's for gay men.
So I don't give a fuck. I need underwear,
right? Gay Men still wear underwear.
So I walk in there and it
was just like Jesus Christ.
It was like cock rings on the
fucking wall, which by the way,
I thought that was the same is like, uh,
like when people get their Dick Pierce,
which I still don't know where they
do that. It's like a navel ring,
but it's on your Dick. So I
thought a cock ring, you know, I,
I thought that that was the same thing,
but it wasn't, it was like a, uh,
look like something you'd use in plumbing,
like a gasket.
Evidently you put that around your
Dick for some reason. Then what?
You Swivel your hips and it's like,
oh,
it's like a hula hoop for
your dick evidently. Right?
So I fucking go in the back and the
underwear, it's like ridiculous.
It was like all these Fred Flintstone
prince, you know what I mean?
There was like Asilis Shit.
And then I finally find a pair that was
just all black and on the waistband it's
said nasty pig.
So
finally just yell over to the
dude behind the counter, go, hey,
you got any like normal like mainstream
underwear here? And he's like,
defy normal or main street.
And I was like, oh, I don't,
it doesn't say nasty pig on the phone.
The waistband it as
material around the ass.
And when it does, it doesn't say fuck
my whole on the back, you know, regular,
just underwear. It's like, hang on.
And he fucking comes over there and he
ended up finding some that would just,
we'll all black, you
know, Greg Louganis style.
But uh, they will, the only
size they had was small,
which was fucking hilarious to
me because I was just like, yeah,
why would you have a medium?
This is like gay guys.
They want to see that their boyfriends
junk spilling out the side. Oh,
you nasty pig.
So I had the leave there and the
closest place was fucking Tj Maxx.
Oh my God.
The fucking animals.
Okay.
Uh,
half of it was the way they had the store,
like the way they had this store set up,
it's just like,
it was so fucked up. It's like,
it was like I was in Manhattan,
the crown jewel of fucking
cities in the United States.
Right. And the second I
walked into fucking Tj Maxx,
I mean I might as well Ben at a fucking
Walmart in the middle of nowhere.
And I am talking down to Middle
America and they're Walmart's.
I am talking down to it,
although I'm not actually,
you know those Walmarts aren't that
bad other than on black Friday.
Black Friday is a day you don't want to
fucking go down there cause that's like
white people, bloods and crips,
you know, that's our version of it.
It's flannels and fucking in flip flops.
That's,
that's our bloods and crips and that
you don't still want to be there on that
day. You know when they have one Atari
for $3 way in the back of the store and
everybody's just basically
going to trample people.
Like they go into the fucking who concert
Cincinnati way back in the day there.
I mean other than that, you know,
it's not, it's not that bad a store,
you know,
it's got all kinds of food,
giant selections. I've gone
in there a bunch of times.
I don't know why I brought that up.
I just don't know what the fuck I'm
talking about this point. Oh TJ Maxx,
you get the Max bowl,
the number at Tj Maxx.
Um, so I go in there and it's, you know,
typical Manhattan fucking store where
it's like half the stores downstairs and
the others in is on the ground floor on
the others is like upstairs, you know,
cause they slammed this
little fucking store in there
and um,
finally find some underwears
and uh, I'm like, fuck,
I got to stand in this God
damn like Disneyland level
line. And like, all right,
they got 12 fucking registers open.
So even though there's like 24 people,
you know,
roughly each one of these cashiers just
knocks out to people and then it's turn,
all right, this shouldn't be this bad.
And it was this woman in front of me.
I don't know what kind of soap she used,
but like I would divorce her,
I swear to God, even if she made my
heart stop, I'd be like, I love you.
I wish nothing for you.
But this fucking soap,
it's a specific soap. I've smelt it
before. It wasn't, she didn't smell bad.
She smelled of this soap. I don't
know what the fuck it is, but it just,
I can't be around it but I had to beat
or someone's going to cut me and then
they just walked you through,
you know the Disneyland thing where
you walk all the way to the right.
Then you go back to the left, you know,
zig zagging all the way up. It just the,
the shit that they had,
you know,
the impulse buys in everybody. If they
weren't staring at their fucking phones.
We're just picking up these things and
the more I saw people picking up the shit,
looking at it like the angry or I was
getting like, why are you picking that up?
You don't need that. Let me find you
the names of these fucking things. Okay.
They had this one thing it said, I would
thank you from the bottom of my heart,
but for you,
my heart has no bottom.
And it was just framed in this piece of
shit would frame and on a white piece of
paper with just regular font
like please don't walk away with the
bathroom key, like the same kind of font,
you would use it that at the gas
station they wrote that fucking cheesy
heartfelt message.
And what the fuck was the next one?
Oh, it was just some sort
of like coconut almonds,
yummy clusters or something was called.
I know
that's how I was able to, this is like
this is the demographic come in, let's,
let's become fat fucks and talk
about how we love each other.
I don't want to talk about,
so I'll get the underwear and I
fucking get back to the hotel room.
And I realize in my looking
down at everybody in Tj Maxx,
I forgot to get socks so I had to
go back to the gay store, you know.
Okay.
And, um, you know,
I come walking into the store and the
same dudes behind the counter and I was
just like, dude, you got a,
you sell socks here, you know,
cause all he had was white sox.
I was going to sit down at church and
they were going to come up and they're
like ankles, like Nike socks. I was
going to with like fucking wing tips.
I wasn't going to do that.
So they actually had regular socks.
So that's what I learned at the gay store.
They just had regular Nike socks,
but for some reason the tag
on him took a picture of it.
I got to send this, I'm going
to going, you know what?
I'm going to tweet this out or whatever.
The tag on the socks just said, bitch,
please.
There's just some,
I guess woman or maybe a guy in
drag with his face all twisted up.
Um, I got on bitch please.
Socks by Nike, you know,
and they feel normal.
These are made for gay feet,
but for some reason they seem
to fit mine just, just fine.
I don't know what the fuck
I'm talking about. Um,
I mentioned earlier that I hadn't been
meditating and it came to a head so to
speak. And uh, remember
when I was bitching,
updating my fucking phone and then trying
to update my laptop and there's no one
to call and I'm typing in
the right passwords and the
two are not in sync and I
don't know how to do it.
I finally had a meltdown and my laptop
was closed and I took my phone and I just
fucking slammed it down like
corner first onto my laptop,
you know, somewhere between
a jab in an overhand right.
But it was a stabbing motion and uh,
I dunno what
then I fucking open my laptop
in the screen was broken.
So my question I have for you guys
okay,
is not, do I need anger management?
I know I do. My question is,
is can people just fix a fucking screen?
Do you can do that.
It's not the hard drive. It was no
water get, they just take that out.
It's like I got a broken windshield and
my laptop and they can they do that?
I'm going to find out,
I'm going to find out because once again
I didn't back up anything there and I
was just really thinking like I did back
anything up and I didn't back anything
up my phone when I dropped it in the
toilet. But do I miss any of that data,
data, whatever the fuck you say
it. And the reality is is I don't.
Okay.
I mean, most of my pictures is taking
pictures of shit that I hate. You know,
people's dirty feet and fucking heartfelt
photos and gay socks that say bitch,
please. I mean, do I, do I really
need to save these somewhere?
I just loved the idea that these
exist somewhere in a cloud,
in this cease fucking people trying to
figure out with the shit that I take a
picture of. Like what can they
sell me next? K Gay socks,
coconut clusters.
I would thank you from the
bottom of my heart, but for you,
my heart has no problem.
Okay.
This is a fat gay male
with a sugar addiction.
Yeah.
And a foot fetish.
Um, anyways, so I got to
read, um, oh, by the way,
my daughter laugh for
the first time yesterday,
twice and I was on the road and I didn't
get to see, I didn't get to hear it, but,
um, I'm hanging out with
her all, all day today, um,
other than the benefit I
have to do tonight and I'm
really like psyched. Like, um,
I came home and of course dropped
everything and picked her up and um,
okay.
She just smiled for like three
minutes straight, which was amazing.
And I could tell she was getting sleepy
and I can read her body language.
She was on the floor and she
started doing this thing,
like she's trying to sit up and my guard,
she wants to get up and I just put
her on my lap and we were watching
these people in Maine rebuild
cabins or some shit and um,
I felt her start to slump
slumped to the right.
And I knew that she was falling asleep
and she was asleep, which as I was like,
this is a perfect time to do the podcast,
but felt so awesome her just laying there.
Then I stayed there for like
another 20 minutes and I'm,
I'm kind of breaking down parenting into
just like sections where I know like I
was like, all right, I got 18 years
with her before she goes off to college.
God willing, so how many months
is that? I just did three of them.
And then the other big countdown
is the first three years.
So the first three years,
all I have to do is just fill
her up with love support.
And when I do lose my
temper because I'm going to,
I'm going to apologize to her and
ask her to help me work on it.
So she's not like necessarily afraid, you
know, I just don't, I got to kill this,
uh, this aspect of my family tree cause
everything else is pretty, uh, you know,
acceptable.
But I don't want to be the guy stabbing
his fucking laptop with this phone,
freaking his kid out. Do I do, you know,
who wants to be that person and you
laying on your death bed one day and they
come walk in and you know,
peaking and still nervous to be around
you just be like, yeah, sorry. Yeah,
sorry.
Are you
back at eight two dash 82
I don't want to have that. So, um, yeah,
I'm hanging out with her all day today,
reading books and the whole thing.
So I've also decided like, all right,
so I still gotta do my two weekends a
month. So those would be like six days.
I won't see her,
but I'll actually see her more than if
I had like a nine to five because then I
can come home and just totally
focused on her, you know,
for the next 10 days before I go
out on the road. So, you know,
and every person that's apparent,
they all say it goes by so fast,
it goes by so fast. So I just keep
thinking that every fucking time. Um,
every day. So hopefully, hopefully, you
know, hopefully I don't fuck this up,
but I'm not gonna lie to you. I know
I'm a mess, so I'm definitely, uh,
you know, the jury's out. Hate people walk
her home a great dead. I'm a great dad.
Shut the fuck up. That's not for you to
say somebody says that to you. You can't,
um, you know, awesome.
You know he's awesome.
You know why? Because I said
so. Um, all right. Audible.
Okay, here we go. Get some reads
here. This is the advertising audible.
Lou Audible. Okay. Louis Black's
new book, the Great Louis Black,
uh,
Lewis Black.
The rant is due is the new original
comedy series from audible channels.
I thought it was a book. I said it
was a book. Louis flex notebook.
You can hear the latest episode for Free
Right now at audible.com/lewis Black.
Now who the fuck would want to hear a
book written by a re written and read by
Louis Black? I'm doing this. Um,
this show is written by the fans.
Uh,
you can't,
you can rant about everything
from politics to relationships
to anything that's
driving you mad by submitting your
rant to Lewis Black right now.
And listening to the rant is due for
free at audible.com/lewis Lewis Black.
For anyone that doesn't know Louis Black,
he's a comedy hero,
a regular on the daily show.
He's got up specials on
HBO and Comedy Central.
He's the voice of anger in inside
out and he's got over a million fans
connecting everyday on social media.
Uh,
I remember the first
time I saw Louis Black,
I saw him at the comedy cellar
right before he blew up.
He was about my age,
maybe a little younger,
about 45 46 and it was one of
those fucking hot brutally.
Okay.
Hot summer days.
In La.
And he came and still wearing his sport
coat and all that and he was just like
miserable.
Okay.
He already walks around with
a certain level of agitation,
which I could totally relate to is,
remember I said I walk around at a six
so going up to 10 isn't that quick of a
ride.
So Louis came in and there was
like nobody in the fucking club.
It was like the mid nineties,
like 95,
96 and comedy was still
dealing with the 80s hangover,
still waiting to make another comeback.
And uh,
so he goes in there in front
of like three fucking people.
I don't have three tables of people,
whatever.
And I had never seen him
and he got in there and
okay,
he was legit upset about how fucking
hot it was outside and then you combine
that with his material and
his stage persona and he
got that finger going and it
was like,
I'll never forget that
I was fucking dying.
This guy when he was in front
of like 11 people murdering,
like he was at Carnegie Hall and um,
that was just one of those great jet just
moved to New York and it was just one
of those great, oh my God,
who the fuck is this guy?
How have I never seen this guy?
How doesn't everybody know who
this guy is? And within like three,
I was like 95,
96 and I want to say he hit around like
99 w was quick within like by 1999 I
think he went on the road and he did that.
Um,
that classic comedy tour lineup.
It was him,
Mitch Hedberg and Dave Attell.
Can you believe that? That
was a fucking tour. Hey,
we're going to go out and go see
comedy tonight. Oh yeah. Who you seen?
I don't know this Guy Louis Black,
this up and coming guy.
Mitch Hedberg Hedberg I'm trying to
think of a David tell had his show yet.
Um,
and I think he had insomniac.
Maybe Mitch had his half hour up,
but um,
I didn't even get to see that fucking
talk cause I was too busy slugging it out
my fucking hell rooms. I would have
loved to have seen that. Um, so anyways,
so I'm sitting here,
Babylon are supposed to be reading a
advertise. I'm telling stories.
All right. Frame bridge everybody.
Yeah.
So weird. I just shot one day on a
movie and Framingham, Framingham,
Massachusetts out there on
fucking off of route nine.
I believe I used to do the Nixon
Framingham up there a long time ago,
over 20 years where they go,
all right,
frame bridge everybody give your
personal experience using frame,
bridge.com if applicable. I've never
used it. It sounds like a great idea,
but I stabbed my fucking
laptop in the face,
stabbed in the face. I always have to say
in the face, you know what that's from.
That's from uh,
the great performance given by that
cop in the bathroom in reservoir dogs.
The way he, the rhythm of the way
he speaks is soap. Like perfect cop.
I said, buddy, I am going
to shoot you in the face.
You don't put your fucking hands.
And that dashboard,
that's one of those movies when
you've seen it that many times,
like all the usual lines and everybody
quotes out of the fucking blue. You know,
I'm trying to be a fucking professional.
You always got big kill asshole.
All those ones that everybody knows.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Bam, Bam, Bam,
Bam, Bam. Look at dam and done.
What I told them not to do. Um,
everybody knows those lines. But then
once you want, once you get up to like,
you know, three, 400 viewings of it,
which you really can do on a summer if
you fucking put your mind to it and you
have no social life like me.
Yeah. That's when you start going,
who the fuck is this guy playing this cop?
The way he's killing this monologue?
Um, I dunno. I Dunno why.
It just reminded me of this comedian
Denny live from Philly and I remember when
he was, he was doing this white
Guy Dan. He's a black dude.
So he's doing this white guy. And the
way he was doing the cadence and the way,
the way the guy was talking was,
uh, you know, that was like sort of,
uh, at the height of the fallout
of the hacky white guy. Like James.
Like I got to do my taxes,
like that fucking thing that
he was actually legitimately
doing a white guy, uh,
like an impression that I
couldn't even fucking do,
but I could see the dude that he
was doing. Um, I don't know those,
those are the nerd things that I like when
I'm watching shit. But anyways, frame,
bridge, um, no, no experience
with the go to frame bridge.com.
Choose your frame or let their
designers help you choose.
Upload your photo from your
computer or directly from Instagram.
Preview your photo online in the
frame you choose. Exclamation point.
This is where it's getting exciting.
Everybody can upload your photo or art.
Don't stab your laptop with
your smart phone. No worries.
You can mail it.
You can mail it in for free.
It's affordable. This is, this is,
that part is totally for
fucking old people like me.
You can call up the pony express.
You can do it that way. Uh,
the expert team at frame bridge.
We'll custom frame your item in days,
not weeks or months and deliver your
finished piece directly to your door.
Ready to hang.
Frame Bridge offers a happiness guarantee.
Uh, their team. I hate when they
do shit like that. Are you happy?
We're just doing a follow up call.
Will you 100% satisfied?
I don't think I've ever been 100%
satisfied about anything. Well,
that kind of goes against our
team spirit awards. Alright,
I'll lie to you. I'm 100% satisfied
with my fucking photo of, you know,
impulse items at Tj Maxx.
Um,
their team gives each item personal
care and attention because meeting your
expectation is as important
as meeting their own. Yeah,
somebody cracking the whip over there.
Uh,
don't get stuck searching for a
last minute gift order for now.
For Mother's Day delivery. Go
to frame. That's a great idea.
Picture of you and your mom. You
know, she's going to love that.
This is cheapest shit. It's perfect for
all you tightwads that love your mom,
but don't think she's good enough
to spend money. This is what you do.
Go to frame bridge.com and use
Promo Code [inaudible] B. U. R.
R you'll save an additional
15% off your first order.
Just go to frame bridge.com,
Promo Code burr frame,
bridge.com Promo Code [inaudible].
All right, here we go.
Um, how many more of these fucking things?
Two more of these things. All right. Oh,
blue apron, everybody speaking
and getting rid of your man tits.
This is a good way to do
it. And ladies, you'll,
you'll be able to keep your
tits and get rid of you see B,
which is right below. You know what
I mean? It's between Yahoo. Uh,
and you Teddy's the old CB there.
I'm
sorry, Blue Apron. Everybody
remember that fucking movie that was
just on the CB was just above fucking
truckers. Kris Kristofferson
was, was in it. And uh,
Ernest Borgnine was, was the state
trooper up there in the helicopter convoy.
And I remember they were trying to get
this fucking convoy of trucks to just
stop driving.
It was like vanishing point with like 70,
72,000 fucking 18 wheelers.
They just,
when they weren't stopping for nothing,
man,
they were just out there and you're
just going to keep on driving.
So these cops were trying to stop them
and they for some reason couldn't send
out Ernest Borgnine, you know, sort of
the go between, between truckers and cops.
Like he understands him. So there's
some cut up in the elevator going, hey,
you fucking truckers. This is, this is
the place where up here to helicopter,
uh, we really don't have
a gun turn or anything,
but we're watching you so you
better be nervous. You know,
he's trying to make threats up
there in his fucking helicopter.
So Ernest Borgnine, it just
shakes his head. He goes at, it,
ain't going to listen to
that. And he grabs the CB,
goes these truckers, he goes,
they got a language all their own and
then he goes to talk to them down there
and he goes,
this is the bear in the air.
The,
I forget how you delivered that line.
Even fucked it up.
This is the bear in the air,
like smokey the bear, you know,
smokey the cop and all of them.
Do I have to break it down to,
you know,
that's one of the things that
I can't fucking stand. I hate
when obvious slang people feel
that they have to break it down to,
you know what I mean?
I remember one time I saw this
one man show and the guy goes,
we were going into Maddie Hattie.
He goes,
that's Manhattan for all you white
people. I want to be like, oh,
it was so slick. And Claire, I mean,
you're almost saying man at and,
and of course they got a laugh. White
people, they don't understand things.
Um, all right, let's get, what am I, am I
technically in the middle of a read here?
All right. Blue Apron. Yeah.
All right. Yeah. This is,
this is about food and aprons.
Okay.
Blueprints.
Mission is to make incredible home
cooking accessible to everyone. All right?
It's about time.
Up until in the button until blue apron,
only the upper 1% were allowed
to have food prepared for them.
All the rest of us were
fucking nine on bushes. Uh,
because blue apron ships the exact amount
of each ingredient required for the
recipe. You better not fucking
spill anything. Uh, no.
They are reducing food waste because
it's the exact amount you bought.
Bastards.
You're going to be like a crack head
crawling around a motel fucking floor
looking for a rock. Did the
bays will go under the bed. Uh,
cooking together, build
strong family bonds, juniors.
It's time to put in the sugar.
Research shows, research it.
Research shows that Blue Apron families
cook nearly three times more often.
Those who spend a lot at restaurants or
at high end grocery stores can now spend
under $10 per person for a
delicious meal each meal.
It's a weird word. Just realize that meal,
you guys want to have a meal. Hey Neil,
you want a meal?
Each meal comes with a step by step,
easy to follow recipe card and pre portion
ingredients and can be prepared in 40
minutes or less.
Blue aprons freshness guarantee promises
that every ingredient in your delivery
arrives ready to cook or
they'll make it right.
Check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals for free with free
shipping by going to blue apron.com/burr
you'll love how good it feels and
tastes to create incredible home cooked
meals with blue apron. Said, oh wait,
that's blue apron.com/burr blue apron.
A better way to cook.
I love that blue apron.
There's just so many different ways you
can do that. Line. Read Blue Apron up pat.
Oh wait. A Cook, right? Like fucking
ving. Rhames we have the meats.
How great is that fucking
advertising campaign?
I have never had a desire to eat there
ever. It's like, I don't want fast food.
Roast beef.
Does anything fucking die quicker
than fucking roast beef? I mean,
I know it's dead already.
You know,
rotting flesh is all you fucking
stupid fucking vegetarians.
Talk about like your plant's not
dead already to the such dopes.
They really are. Um, all of
them. Every single one of them.
I put them all in one group because
that's what I do because I don't take the
time to get to know people.
Okay. And right now it's,
I think this country needs a little
more of that, don't you? All right. Cso,
everyone attention comedy nerds come
to a magical place called CSO where new
standup comedy specials debut every month.
This month they have big Jay Oakerson
with what's your fucking deal?
A standup series featuring nothing
but Crowdwork. That's funny, man.
From bigJ and dozens of headlining comics.
That's a fucking great name for a show.
Which your fucking deal.
I just picture a big Jay sitting there on
the stool just looking around and shit.
Fucking deal. Huh? What'd he do?
Is it filling you up with Cecil?
You get unlimited access to seeso
original series this next day,
late night. A hilarious standup
specials. Binge worthy classics,
including 42 seasons of Saturday
night live. That's crazy.
Anyone you want to watch the
entire Monty python catalog,
the it crowd and more sign up now to
catch brand new standup specials from the
Great Nick Depaulo.
Okay.
From the incredible Joey co go.
Sorry. I tried to do it like Michael
Buffer. Uh, Bruce Buffer. Actually,
I was trying to do Bruce buffer and
the new season of big J auger since.
What's your fucking deal or watch your
favorite sets from comedians like Fahim
Anwar Pronounced Faheem aren't Anwar Dude.
You know what?
Does everybody have to stay
on big Jay Oakerson show?
Do you have to say what's your fucking
deal? You got to say it. I mean,
it's almost like a game show,
right? All of it higher.
You know this, there's certain
things that you have to say.
I can't think of a catchphrase from
a game show. Anyways. Hey Bill,
the shows already a hit.
It's in its second season.
They don't need you fucking retooling it.
It's like some ghosts producer.
Fair enough. All right. Access. See,
so content from anywhere at
anytime using Ios, android,
Roku, apple TV, Amazon fire, Amazon,
fire TV. That sounds like
a bad fucking, I dunno.
Vodka or Cologne or some shit.
Windows on or Xbox one.
Ready for the pump. Xbox one. Sorry. Ready
for the punch line. I thought one ready?
Wasn't even one of those things. Ready
for the punchline? Yes, Bell. We are.
CSO is just three 99 per month.
No joke.
Three 99 per month for all the comedy
you want anytime, anywhere. Ad Free,
ad free. You're listening to an ad
right now. How annoying is this? You're,
you're free of this.
Just go to [inaudible] dot
com s e s o.com Sierra Echo,
Echo Sierra,
oscar.com right now to sign up for
one month for free with Promo Code
[inaudible] at checkout.
That's [inaudible] dot
com spelled s e s o.com,
Promo Promo Code [inaudible]
seeso.com Promo Code Bar.
All right. Not to nitpick, but I
would've spelled it s e e s o. O.
So when you spell it out, you know,
two eat two s's. Two e's, two o's. See,
so Cecil, um, all right,
let's plow ahead here.
Um, all right. Okay. Oh Jesus,
Boston sports. Let's Talk Boston
sports. Dudded add that data.
Um, Jesus, what a couple of fucking
games those were. Um, all right,
let's start with the Boston Bruins.
We've lost three games
straight to the Ottawa.
Um, I missed the law. Um,
I missed yesterday night's game
cause I was at the memorial service,
but I definitely watched game two and
game three. And although we had a furious,
got back and gave three, it was not
enough. I was actually in the north end.
I mean the cigar bar smoking his stogy
hoping it was going to be a good thing.
Um, what a fuck. And that was a great goal
though. And over time it'll give and go.
Got To admit. And, uh, I dunno. I Dunno.
They just been out playing us and they,
they deserve it.
Now granted it was a shit call but
there's going to be shit calls.
It's just going to
happen. But uh, you know,
yeah,
I dunno. Shit call a no shit call.
We've lost three games in a row.
So I mean get all,
you can only look in the mirror.
So we'll see what happens.
Um,
the excitement of the Bruins making
the playoffs is quickly subsiding here.
I would like to see them win a series
and now there they got their fucking
back's up against the wall.
So we'll see. We'll see.
We'll see when game five comes
up, I imagine tomorrow. All right.
And then the Celtics,
oh,
Jesus Celtics have been
completely exposed.
I know that that's probably
been said a thousand times.
You know what's funny is when
I first got back into the NBA,
which I got back into it cause Paul Versey
was coming out here and he loves the
NBA and he was staying with me,
him and his lovely wife staying with me
and my lovely wife for like four or five
days and a I'm a hell of a host or
what a host, what a host. Right.
So I'm just like, all right, well you
know, I would first he's coming to town,
I got to get some Johnny blue,
I got to get the NBA package
so he can watch his Nixon.
I just got into the Celtics.
So I've been watching him since uh,
December of 2015. And my first
thought when I was watching him,
I was like,
where are we going to go with this game
plan where we have this superstar point
guard, we live and die by the three
and we don't get any fucking rebound.
So like I don't understand
how you can win.
Yeah.
Anything
playing basketball like that.
But then here's what happened.
They did and they just kept
winning and everybody else,
it just became socially acceptable on
the hard court to fucking run down the
court with the ball. Three people. Right.
Okay.
From the other team onto the net.
Nobody on your team or maybe one guy.
It was totally acceptable to say,
I'm not waiting for my other teammates
and I'm just going to launch a fucking
three, you know, and we're up by one with
like fucking eight minutes to go like,
what are you doing? But
that just, you know,
the same way after Jordan,
people were just like, well,
I guess we don't need to feed it to a big
man. Do we even need a big man, Randy?
[inaudible]. So I was like, all
right, I guess this is the new game.
So we ended up not only doing great
this year once we added Al Horford.
Yeah,
we fucking got the number one seed.
And at that point I completely forgot
about my initial reaction to the way that,
that they were playing. And I was
like, all right, I guess, yeah.
With a number one seed, we
get an eight seat. All right.
And after the first two
games, it's like a, you know,
it seems like the opposite.
Seems like they're the number one seat
and where the eight seat and I kind of
knew we were in trouble.
Uh,
I guess,
well when Charles Barkley just basically
broke our team down after the first
half or the first game going,
yeah,
you just basically you double team Isaiah
tried to make a beat the double and
then if these guys don't hit their threes,
you know, they're not getting any fuck.
I don't know what the hell he said,
but it's just like, all right,
this guy's already figured this out.
Basically what I'm saying is, um,
I think this is the first
real test for Brad Stevens,
this next game where he has to make a
drastic adjustment with the players that
he has because they figured
this out before the opening
tip off and that has led
to two losses and we have not been
able to make any adjustment. And,
um,
what's fascinating about the bowls is
even though that they're an eighth seed,
they got Rondo and they got Dwayne
Wade and Rondo's got a ring and I think
Dwayne Wade, he's got what?
Three rings, four rings, he won,
one was shack and then two with
Lebron. Lebron, I can't remember,
I'm not a big NBA guy.
He's got at least three weeks.
So there's four rings right there.
Those guys have been
through it numerous times.
So they're not afraid of the
ebbs and flows of the game.
They're not afraid of playing on the road.
They're just totally chill.
And I think that affects
the rest of the team.
And then he got Butler and Lopez who
have just fucking animals just hitting,
you know, 12 foot jumpshot's 15 footers
while getting all these rebounds.
And then that fucking white dude from
Europe Vladi devakt junior d voc jr he's
fucking started hitting threes.
And um,
okay.
You know, we're getting asses kicked, so
I'll see what happens.
And you know, but uh,
Jesus Christ, I mean, we were down
three to one in hockey and went down,
oh to going out to Chicago.
So I'm hoping I'm
okay.
I'm hoping. Yeah. Jesus. So we
don't get fucking swept. I mean,
I dunno. Brutal, brutal, brutal. But
you know, what are you gonna do it?
And it's just a fucking game. I realized
that if the first one when I'm watching,
you know, Isaiah Thomas
crying about losing this sift,
it was a really a brutal week
for that type of shit. Huh?
An Aaron Hernandez hung himself.
Man, that was fucking brutal.
The whole thing was brutal.
And then all those fucking jokes that
people were making like, oh yeah,
he got hung up. He's got an upper
body injury to the fucking neck.
Oh, all this dumb shit. Um, that,
that shit to me is always weird.
Where are you going to sell that guy's a
murderer. He's a fucking piece of shit.
And uh, and then everybody acts like a
fucking animal when he kills himself.
MMM.
Of course there's people out there
that don't, that think, you know,
something else happened.
It's like, all right,
you got just got acquitted on those
other two murders and then you had a good
chance for an appeal. You
know, you had some hope. Um,
but I dunno who the fuck knows.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
I don't necessarily agree with that
or disagree. I have no fucking idea.
But I do know was I think if any
sort of a fucking human being,
the whole thing was just sad.
It's just like, you know,
it's just all these lives just
fucking thrown away over nothing.
Granted,
you know,
obviously he pulled the fucking trigger
and everything like that, but still,
I don't take any sort of a, I don't
know. Honestly, I didn't get that.
I was just like, ah. It was just,
yeah, it's one of those things.
He's just from front to back.
You just wish it didn't happen.
And everybody's like, oh, hey,
here's my fucking obvious joke.
Um, so anyway. Oh God.
Am I really gonna be talking
about fucking him killing himself?
Is that how I'm going to end this
podcast? How long has this podcast, Ben?
43 minutes. While you know what?
I'm in overtime. All right,
let's end up on something
positive tonight.
Of course I'm working tonight and this
fucking band that I've been wanting to
see cause it drummers, amazing. I
don't have his name in front of me.
I should have it,
but I don't spend called
Russian circles is playing.
MMM.
Is playing at the uh, oh for fuck sakes.
What's the name of the fucking thing?
Every goddamn theater begins with a
p out here. Hang. I gotta hit pause.
I got to make sure I have this information
hung. Hang on the palladium. Fuck.
Get ticket.
Paramont the pompadour the
fucking palladium actually
that's where Richard Pryor,
uh, tape, uh, live on the sunset strip.
So I was introduced to this band.
They played this song,
Harper Louis Live and uh,
their drummer absolutely fucking
blew me away with his, um,
just how solid
his is.
His beats were,
and then his use of dynamics.
It's just on a whole other fucking level,
which I really think is a lost art. Um,
but they're playing tonight,
um, since 6:30 PM. And, uh,
I wish I could go,
but I got a fucking God damn
benefit so I can't make it.
But I'll post that clip of the band
playing that song. Harper Lewis.
It's the live version and just the way,
you know,
it just starts off with the drum beat
that he's playing and he's playing it,
you know, it gradually
builds in intensity, gets
louder and louder. And then,
uh, then when they go into that, I
don't, it's an instrumental band.
I don't know how to say versus chorus.
I don't know what the fuck they're doing,
but just absolutely blew me away.
If you've got nothing to do tonight,
you want to see a killer band, go down
and get a couple of tickets to that.
I guarantee you have a great time.
Um, all right, that is the podcast.
Um, Eh, I guess cause it's
four 20, like weed man,
I guess a, Andrew's going to be
giving you guys some extra clips.
It's going to be a little bit
longer and a, and that is it.
And it was an honor to be a
Charlie Murphy's memorial service.
It was an honor to know that
guy. And I want to thank, uh,
everybody who spoke that night.
Last night though,
the way that they sent that guy
off, it was just like, it was
okay.
It just was a level of greatness in
the performances that I saw from the
comedians that went up and spoke. And, um,
okay.
Charlie was one of the greats,
you know, and it was just,
it was such a perfect sendoff and I'm
really glad that I was able to be there
and witness it. All right.
So that's it. I'll, uh,
you fucking cunts have
a great weekend and, uh,
enjoy this music and some,
uh,
some clips from a podcast recorded
Monday or a Thursday gone by.